[Musique]
nouveau souci pour la communauté
économique européenne le beurre exporté
en quantité massive vers les pays de
l'est et d'amérique latine se fait de
plus en plus rare chez nous et débouche
pratiquement aujourd'hui sur une
situation de pénurie il s'agit
entendons-nous du beurre d'intervention
et de ses excédents
la situation est telle que les
industriels de la biscuiterie tire le
signal d'alarmé met en garde bruxelles
plusieurs usines distille pourrait en
effet cessé leur activité faute de ce
beurre d'intervention pour fabriquer des
gâteaux pur beurre on utilise uniquement
du beurre d'intervention c'est à dire un
beurre que l'on a stocké parce qu'il y
en a trop et surtout un beur qui coûte
moins chère que le beurre mise en vente
libre
alors pour écouler ce beurre
excédentaire l'europe a surtout tenté de
l'exporter en europe de l'est bien sûr
mais aussi en amérique du sud et au
proche orient et ses exportations aussi
bien marché que les eurocrates ont
oublié dans leurs prévisions la part des
industriels de la biscuiterie
résultat le beurre d'intervention
utilisé par les biscuiteries vient à
manquer et moins il y en a plus son prix
augmente la situation risque d'être
catastrophique pour de nombreuses
biscuiterie et surtout les biscuiteries
bretonne pour le consommateur
l'augmentation des gâteaux risque d'être
de l'ordre de 20 à 25%
reste la possibilité pour les
industriels de s'approvisionner sur le
marché libre du beurre à 19 francs le
kilo mais à condition que l'europe
veuille bien payer la différence par
rapport aux prix d'intervention
cela coûterait cher à l'europe et le
résultat serait le contraire de ce que
les technocrates de bruxelles
est-ce qu'on est au départ à savoir
réduire les dépenses agricoles de
l'europe
[Musique]